Jan Zizka (aka Jan Žižka z Trocnova a Kalicha)
is regarded as one of the single finest military
minds in world history.
He also had his skin turned into a drum.
Before we get to his death, though, we want
to discuss Zizka’s life, because well, frankly
it was remarkable.
For starters, Zizka, born in 1360, is generally
considered to have never lost a battle.
What makes this feat even more impressive
is that, whereas the few other generals in
history who’ve done this had powerful armies
at their command, Zizka was in command of
only peasants and rebels.
Zizka was a general during something known
as the “Hussite Wars” which, in a nutshell,
was an uprising by protestant dissenters against
the Catholic Church.
The Hussites, who were mostly Czechs, followed
the teachings of Jan Hus, a Czech priest who
was burned at the stake for heresy in 1415.
You can read an eyewitness account of Hus’
death, here, if you’re interested in that
sort of thing.
But we’re getting a little head of ourselves,
prior to becoming a general for the Hussites,
Zizka was actually a mercenary fighting for
whomever paid him the highest wage.
It was during his time as a mercenary, during
the First Battle of Tannenberg (aka, the Battle
of Grunwald) in 1410, that Zizka lost one
of his eyes.
After getting his eye stabbed out of his face,
Zizka was still instrumental in helping claim
victory that day for the Polish.
Around four years after Hus had been executed,
in 1419, the Hussites following his teachings
took the first few steps towards a full scale
revolt against the Catholic church by storming
the town hall in Prague.
Led by Zizka and a priest called, Jan Želivský,
a group of Hussite protesters threw 7 (though
some sources say 11) city councilors from
a window.
Supposedly, the protesters never set out with
the intention of violence; originally they
were just there to petition for the release
of a group of unfairly imprisoned fellow Hussites.
However, the crowd began baying for blood
when an unknown person from within the town
hall threw a stone at them.
The protest and subsequent riot is known as
The First Defenestration of Prague.
The First Defenestration of Prague is widely
accepted as the event that kick-started the
Hussite Wars which lasted all the way until
1434.
Luckily for the Hussites, under the leadership
of Zizka, they won victory after victory,
despite generally being vastly outnumbered.
Zizka’s prowess on the battlefield was linked
to a combination of his ability to effectively
use the terrain of the battlefield to his
advantage and his amazing ability to innovate,
including being among the first to effectively
incorporate small gun powder weapons in battle
and developing what were essentially tanks.
We’re not using hyperbole here by the way,
Zizka personally oversaw the construction
of “war wagons”- heavily armoured wagons,
from which his men could safely pepper the
enemy to death with crossbow bolts and hand
cannon balls.
These war wagons were instrumental in many
of Zizka’s victories and helped him and
his men overcome almost impossible odds.
For example, during the Battle of Sudomer,
Zizka and a force just 400 lightly equipped
men managed to fight off over 2000 well trained
soldiers.
Though his war wagons were indeed formidable,
Zizka himself didn’t hide behind them, generally
preferring to fight the enemy head on.
His skill and ferocity on the battlefield
quickly earned him the respect of his men,
and his enemies.
In fact, Zizka was so determined to lead his
soldiers regardless of the odds, that he even
did so after he lost his other eye during
a battle in 1421.
Zizka even once managed to lead an ambush
against a group of men who’d tried to ambush
him while he was completely blind in both
eyes.
Zizka continued leading his men until 1424,
when he finally died, not from running into
battle blind, but from the plague.
Before his death though, Zizka requested that
his skin be flayed from his body and used
to make a drum.
We’re guessing that when you read the title
of this piece you assumed that Zizka’s skin
was ripped off by an enemy looking to make
an example of him or something like that,
right?
But no, Zizka’s skin was ripped off at the
personally bequest of Zizka himself.
Why?
So that his men could beat the drum as they
marched into battle; so that even in death,
he could lead them on!